- [Host] This is a different Ricky show.
In which that is an office.
- And an office.
(crosstalk)
He's really creative, isn't he?
- [Host] Yeah (laughs)
- I'm Bobby Berk from Netflix's Queer Eye
and I'm gonna be looking at
some famous British homes.
(gentle music)
I think it's a mess.
I think they need to start taking
and emptying their rubbish bins.
I think they also need
to update your computers
'cause they look like
they're from the 90s.
They need more ergonomical chairs.
It's very boring and depressing.
I wouldn't want to work there.
Maybe that's why they're in the afterlife,
because they've all died
because they work there.
(laughs)
Huh, actually don't mind it.
I like as,
if you've watched Queer Eye,
you know I love a painted cabinet.
It's a bit of a mess.
I mean, it's a huge mess.
It looks like the stove's falling apart.
I'm not a huge fan of a
lavender robe on a dude.
It just doesn't work for him.
I mean to me, and if that's in 10 Downing,
I think it's very typical
of what it should look like,
which is exactly what
I would expect it to be
a little stuffy.
If I were to change it,
I would actually paint
it all white and then I would put some
super modern sofas in it because I love
mixing old and new together.
I love taking old architecture
and making it all one color,
but then putting in
modern furniture with it.
Buckingham Palace, I
think that's beautiful.
It's everything I'd hoped it would be.
I want, love to go in there.
Just so you know Netflix,
you should take me to Buckingham Palace.
It's beautiful.
I mean, it is not my taste at all,
but it's gorgeous.
I can fully respect
different types of style
as long as they're beautiful.
Oh that house looks just awful.
It's awful, awful, awful.
Her hair color's awful,
she needs to stop tanning.
That's exactly what I would
expect in an old British house,
like floral curtains, yeah.
That is, it's just sad.
There was a trailer park down
the street where I grew up
called Lucky Lady Trailer Park
and I would always laugh
at there was really nothing
lucky about any lady
that had to live there.
That's a pub?
It looks like a grandma's house.
Yeah, no, I'm not a fan.
I think it's a bit tacky.
Again, floral curtains,
what's up with the floral?
Why would anyone put
curtains in a pub as well?
That's gotta stink.